>> IT'S THE CUOMOS.
STARRING ANDREW AND CHRIS.
>> Greg: LET'S CHECK IN WITH
THE TWO BROTHERS WHO LOVED
BLAMING OTHERS.
WHAT DID CHRIS CUOMO SAY BEFORE
NOVEMBER?
HE HOPES YOU DON'T REMEMBER.
LOOKS LIKE CHRIS SUFFERED SOME
MEMORY LOSS AFTER HIS BRAVELY
TELEVISED BATTLE WITH CORONA.
ON TUESDAY WHILE TALKING ABOUT
JANUARY 6TH HE CLAIMED HE NEVER
DEFENDED BLACK LIVES MATTER
RIOTERS BACK IN THE DAY.
AND I AM 6'4".
I'M 5'10".
ANYWAY.
FORTUNATELY FOR CHRIS, CNN
VIEWERS, ALL SIX OF THEM, HAVE
SHORT MEMORIES BECAUSE THE TAPE
TELLS A DIFFERENT STORY.
>> AROUND 140 OFFICERS
ASSAULTED, SOME VERY BADLY.
THIS IS THE TRUTH.
PERIOD.
IT IS NO LESS THE TRUTH BECAUSE
BLACK LIVES MATTER SUPPORTERS
COMMITTED ACTS OF VIOLENCE TOO.
EVEN IF YOU WANT TO BELIEVE THAT
THE MEDIA WERE AS OKAY WITH WHAT
THEY DID WHICH IS SURE AS HELL
ISN'T TRUE ON THEIR SHOW AND
PLEASE SHOW ME WHERE IT SAYS A
PROTESTER IS SUPPOSED TO BE
POLITE AND PEACEFUL.
>> Greg: ARE ADORABLE.
MIGHT WANT TO DOUBLE THAT DOSE
OF GINKGO BILOBA.
WE ARE NOT ON WITH YOU YET,
CRISPER LAST NIGHT HE DEFENDED
CRITICAL RACE THEORY, CALL
CALLING OUT CONSERVATIVES FOR
BLOWING IT OUT OF PROPORTION.
>> THE CRITICAL RACE THEORY,
THIS BOGEYMAN, JUST THE NEW
FRONT ON THE CULTURE WAR, THAT'S
ALL.
THE BROWN MENACE IS GONE.
THEY ARE NOT COMING OVER THE
WALL TO, TAKE YOUR WOMEN.
NOW IT'S, THEY ARE COMING TO
TAKE YOUR KIDS.
BUT CRITICAL RACE THEORY IS
REALLY ABOUT IS CHOOSING WHICH
STORIES MATTER IN THE TEACHING
OF THE HISTORY OF AMERICA.
>> Greg: YEAH, THAT'S WHAT IT
IS.
YOU DIDN'T EVEN READ ABOUT IT.
CRITICIZING PEOPLE WHO ACTUALLY
DO THEIR HOMEWORK.
YOU DIDN'T EVEN DO THE HOMEWORK.
CRT IS THE BOGEYMAN?
DUDE, I COULD HAVE SWORN THAT
WAS YOUR BROTHER.
[APPLAUSE]
THE ELECTED BUTT GRABBER
CONTINUES TO LAUGH ALL THE WAY
TO THE BANK AND IN THE FACE OF
COVID VICTIMS.
THIS IS HIM COMMISERATING WITH
HIS FELLOW GOVERNORS YESTERDAY.
>> VERY FEW PEOPLE WERE GOING
THROUGH WHAT WE WENT THROUGH AND
WE WENT THROUGH TOGETHER.
SPEAKING FOR MYSELF IT WAS A
TREMENDOUS PERSONAL BENEFIT.
>> Greg: DOES THIS GUY EVEN
REALIZE WHAT'S COMING OUT OF HIS
MOUTH?
TREMENDOUS PERSONAL BENEFIT?
NURSING HOME RESIDENTS DIED
UNDER YOUR WATCH BUT WHO'S
COUNTING.
HE SCORED A $5.1 MILLION BOOK
DEAL HIKING UP HIS HEROIC
RESPONSE TO THE PANDEMIC.
IT SOLD FEWER COPIES THAN
MICHAEL MOORE'S GUIDE TO TANTRIC
SEX.
YOU STILL HAVE MY COFFEE, BRIAN.
>> Brian: YOU MOVED YOUR
OFFICE.
>> Greg: A FOLDOUT FOLD IN
POLLS.
ONE OF MY DOING?
WHY DO YOU MAKE OF THE GOVERNOR?
ARE WE TAKING THE GOVERNOR OUT
OF CONTEXT?
>> Joe: NO BUT HE'S GOT TO
KEEP HIS MOUTH SHUT PENDING THE
PROCEEDINGS IN THE COURT OF LAW.
HE MIGHT TAKE THE FIFTH
AMENDMENT BEFORE HE SAYS
ANYTHING.
THAT IS THE SMART PLAY.
THEY DEFENDED HIM SO MUCH IN THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA, THEY TALKED
ABOUT HOW WOMEN WERE ATTRACTED
TO HIM WHEN THEY SHOULD HAVE
BEEN LOOKING AT NURSING HOME
NUMBERS.
ONCE THEY SAY THAT HE WAS GOOD,
THEY CAN TELL US THAT HE WAS
BAD.
SO THEY MEMORY HOLE IT.
DOING THE BEST THING POSSIBLE,
KEEP QUIET.
>> Greg: THAT'S TRUE.
KAT, GOVERNOR CUOMO APPROVES OF
HUMAN INDUSTRY ON YOUR SIDE LIKE
THE MEDIA, YOU OUTLAST THE
SCANDALS.
>> Kat: ABSOLUTELY.
HE SAID THE OTHER DAY WE ARE
GOING TO DO WITH GUN VIOLENCE
LIKE WE DID WITH COVID.
YOU'RE GOING TO PUT SHOOTERS IN
THE NURSING HOME?
AND THEN LIE ABOUT IT?
WRITE A BOOK AND MAKE MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS?
WHAT YOU MEAN BY IT?
I CAN'T IMAGINE HOW HE CAN STILL
GO OUT THERE.
HE REALLY DOES SEE HIMSELF AS A
HERO.
HE DOES THINK PEOPLE THINK THAT
ABOUT HIM.
HE DOESN'T REALIZE HOW HORRIBLE
HE REALLY IS.
>> Greg: I'M GOING TO POSE A
THOUGHTFUL QUESTION, NOT THE
USUAL KIND.
YOU ARE A VETERAN OF FOX.
I ALWAYS GET WHEN CHRIS CUOMO IS
DOING HIS COMMENTARY, HE'S NOT
ACTUALLY SPEAKING TO THE
VIEWERS.
HE IS SPEAKING TO HIS PEER
GROUP.
NO ONE REALLY CARES.
DOESN'T CARE ABOUT HIS PERSONAL
FEELINGS ABOUT STUFF.
HE IS DOING THAT TO TALK TO THE
PEOPLE IN THE MEDIA WORLD WHERE
AS WHEN WE ARE TALKING, WE ARE
TALKING TO VIEWERS BECAUSE WE
APPRECIATE OUR VIEWERS AND
BECAUSE WE HAVE THEM.
>> Brian: AND HE BELIEVES HIS
VIEWERS ARE NEW YORK,
WASHINGTON, LOS ANGELES.
PEOPLE HAVE A INADEQUATE,
UNMATCHED UNDERSTANDING.
THEY THINK HE IS MORE POPULAR
THAN ACTUALLY IS BECAUSE THEY
DON'T TRAVEL.
MOST PEOPLE IF YOU TRAVEL TO
PLACES WHERE WE GO LIKE ON OUR
BOOKSTORES.
THEY DON'T WATCH CNN FOR THEY
DON'T KNOW WHAT CNN STANDS FOR.
IN THE CUOMO'S SITUATION, YOU
MENTIONED THAT I'M A VETERAN.
ALL THE YEARS COVERING THE
STORIES, SMALL AND BIG, HAVE
NEVER SEEN SOMEONE SO WRITTEN IN
SCANDAL GET SUCH A PASS.
THIS GUY SHOULD BE HUMILIATED
SOMEWHERE, LIVING ON A FARM IN
SCHENECTADY.
INSTEAD HE CONTINUES.
LAST TIME THEY HAD A MEETING
WITH GOVERNORS, HE WAS SO
WRITTEN IN SCANDAL THEY HAD TO
HAVE A REPUBLICAN FILL IN FOR
HIM.
THIS TIME HE ACTUALLY DID IT
HIMSELF AND MADE THAT STATEMENT.
HE KILLED 50,000 PEOPLE --
50,000 PEOPLE DIED ON HIS WATCH.
TEN SEPARATE WOMEN ACCUSED HIM
OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
USED HIS POWER TO GET DONORS ON
FAMILY MEMBERS TESTS WHEN NO ONE
ELSE HAD THEM.
ANY ONE OF THOSE WOULD'VE
DESTROYED ANYONE FOREVER.
REMEMBER GARY HART?
MET A WOMAN ON AN ISLAND AND HE
WAS DESTROYED.
HOW THIS GUY HAS A STILL HAS A
JOB AND IS RUNNING FOR
REELECTION, I'VE NEVER SEEN
ANYTHING LIKE IT.
>> Greg: HE TRULY IS THE
BRIAN KILMEADE OF GOVERNORS.
>> Brian: NOT TRUE, NOT AN APT
ANALOGY.
HOW DARE YOU.
I HELPED YOUR SHOW.
YOU HURT MY CAREER.
WHAT'S WRONG WITH YOU?
>> Greg: THERE IS A LOT WRONG
WITH ME.
>> Brian: YOU COULD'VE SAID
THAT TO ANY OF THESE THREE.
I TRIED TO GIVE SOME SUBSTANCE.
>> Greg: I WAS LISTENING TO
YOU.
>> Brian: YOU WEREN'T EVEN
PAYING ATTENTION.
>> Greg: I ALWAYS DO.
DAGEN, THE MEDIA HATES WHAT WE
DO BECAUSE IT'S NOT FOR THEM.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT WHAT THEY'RE
DOING, IT'S ALWAYS FOR THE
MEDIA, THAT'S MY POINT I WAS
TRYING TO MAKE TO BRIAN WHICH HE
WENT ON SOME WEIRD TANGENT.
AVENATTI MEMBERS OF THE MEDIA
WHO PAY ATTENTION TO THESE TWO
ARE JEALOUS SIMPLY BECAUSE THEY
WANT THE PATH TO BE AS EASY AS
IT WAS FOR THESE TWO.
THEY WOULD NOT BE ANYWHERE IF
NOT FOR DADDY.
ANDY CUOMO WILL BE SELLING
CATHETERS DOOR-TO-DOOR.
>> Greg: DON'T KNOCK IT.
>> Dagen: CHRIS CUOMO COULDN'T
GET CAST IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD
PLAYHOUSE.
LO AND BEHOLD THEY ARE DOING
THIS FLEX OFF WITH EACH OTHER TO
FIGURE OUT WHO IS THE BIGGEST
LIAR ON THE PLANET.